[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
pâques le premier de l'année 2019 donc
bonne année très bonne année à tous
vous savez qu'en france on adore les
débats donc il va y avoir un grand débat
et avant ce grand débat on va faire un
débat sur le débat est peut-être un
débat sur le débat du débat et parler
avec florence mercadé gay avocate à la
cour d' la cour de versailles
bonjour maîtrise pas seulement le cours
d'apple à toutes les courses
matri bonne année aussi il vous est
toujours maître de conférences à
sciences po
c'était pas de morceaux de la boulimie
avons comme on dit par chez vous et moi
c'est vous c'est nous c'est tout c'est à
la rochelle
non non au sud de la ville c'est plutôt
dans le berry et l'enseigné à la
rochelle d'ailleurs eu oui oui à titre
de loisir dans un amphithéâtre qui a vue
sur mer voilà ça c'est quand même ce qui
vous sauve à peu près de 50 ha oui oui
mais jamais sur la mer il ya moins la
vue sur la mer
c'est vrai les gens femme là je dis
bonjour madame et à éditeurs avec avec
le premier labour pourrait dire c'est le
premier livre de 2019 ont presque mais
presque je vous dis toujours ou presque
on sait ce que c'est c'est deuxième
vingt seize donc l'appétit de la
destruction alors c'est un roman qui se
passe dans le milieu du rock and roll
absolument absolument c'est une
une histoire l'histoire d'un groupe de
rock fictif mais l'histoire de ce groupe
de rock c'est le départ de ce groupe
son ascension son succès et puis ça
sachez et sa chute avec beaucoup de
corps voilà chez fiat voit bien là sur
wii avec tout ce qu'ils votent compagne
l'europe c'est-à-dire il ya la drogue et
la violence il ya tous les excès qu'ils
excellent voilà toutes les folies mais
mais aussi tous ceux tout ce génie tout
ce talent et et c'est assez voire très
très bien écrit et c'est assez
passionnant ça rappelle un peu
l'histoire de deux d'indochine de noir
désir
les stones chose de valable et etc de
yvon romains et les les libraires qui
ont eu la primeur de ce livre on dit le
plus grand bien là ils ont ils ont
beaucoup aimé ce qu'on avait
effectivement ce qu'on fait temps en
temps quand les libraires sont peu
demandeur on envoie des services de
presse des preuves non corrigée enfin
deux ou trois mois avant et là donc ils
ont eu le temps de le lire il on a eu de
très bons retours unc bonnes critiques
de beaucoup de limerick sont très
enthousiastes
l'appétit de la destruction éditions la
joie dit voilà rivaux romains
merci ben c'est un cadeau voilà le défi
non ne prête pas les livres les achètent
oui nous faut que ce qu il faut plus
prêter c'est vrai mais a livré une date
que du monstre du morne oui ça fait six
ans qu'on l'achète pour le ballon pour
donner plutôt découvert un jour un
bouquin génial c'est un copain qui avait
découvert pas idina mais une vingtaine
d'années il avait tellement aimé le
lièvre de vatanen il avait acheté 15
bouquins et à chaque fois qu'il y avait
des amis qui arrivait de données libre
et moi c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert
il m'a dit tiens je te dis ça c'était
vachement bien c'est un très beau risque
d'abord c'est un cadeau très personnelle
des livres des éditions on va pouvoir le
dire quelque chose de gratuit non ici
dit bon cela dit c'est le texte d'
emmanuel macron qui cadre le grand débat
qui commence mardi droit pendant deux
mois jusqu'au mois de mars
est-ce que je me tourne vers les
spécialistes du droit est ce que c'est
ce qu'il ya déjà eu des grands débats
très houleux débat sur l'identité
nationale organisé par nicolas sarkozy
et puis il ya eu 1 je me souviens y
avoir participé
il y avait eu un genre de grand débat
sur l'école
sur l'avenir de l'école la commission
thélot et j'avais été alors je ne sais
plus à quel titre j'ai participé à titre
de parent d'élève à l'époque où je bref
mais ça m'avait beaucoup plus de bruit
de grands témoins ou de d'anciens élèves
d'écoles moi même enfin je ne sais pas
faire de dégâts bien sûr et et ça
m'avait ça m'avait beaucoup plu mais ça
s'était fait dans des dans un contexte
voilà vandalisé au sein duquel les gens
pouvaient se parler et s'écouter
c'était très ciblée sur un soutien ciblé
sur un sur une thématique mais j'avais
j'avais été ralentis on a alors
probablement découvert pour beaucoup
l'existence d'un comité nationale du
débat public
un câble de suite c'est le débat public
caracas alors c'est quoi ce comité
national cette commission est sur votre
mission c'est une autorité alors
administrative a pas publics non
administrative du bâtiment puis ce cas
là quand on parle du salaire de madame
reno elles disent elles mêmes salaires
que les autorités alors s'étonne c'est
une alice se taire ce sont des
organismes qui qui ne sont pas dotés de
la personnalité morale c'est dire c'est
l'état lui-même qui agit par
l'intermédiaire de ces organismes qui
qui ont pénétré les institutions
françaises
à la fin des années 70 globalement et le
on s'est calqué sur des modèles
britannique étasunien ou du nord de
l'europe pour que s'ils voulaient
l'action distractives de l'état en
certains domaines des domaines sensibles
domaine où il faut contrôler des actions
un peu un peu particulière type par son
plat sur la sûreté nucléaire par exemple
la protection des données personnelles
l'accès aux documents administratifs et
puis on a beaucoup d'autres
puisse cette action puisse se réaliser
dans des conditions de d'impartialité de
transparence de brefs dans une action
présentant beaucoup de garanties pour
les droits des administrés et cette
commission nationale du débat public
elle a pour fonction elles font enfin
elle fonctionne vraiment 70 des bas oui
absolument face elle a pour fonction que
des vins c'est d'organiser si elles
l'estiment nécessaire donc des formes de
concertation alors à elle seule elle se
décline en commissions locales du débat
public
en prélude à des grands travaux
d'aménagement il ya eu par exemple un
débat public dans notre région ici dans
notre secteur à propos du prolongement
ou du changement d'itinéraire de la
nationale 10 sur le fait de savoir s'il
fallait que ça passe par parent trap la
verrière ou alors par la vallée de
chevreuse
c'est l'un des exemples sur notre dame
des landes sûr il ya eu des grandes
guerres des grands débats aussi sur
l'agrandissement du port du havre enfin
c'est une commission qui doit la dette
débat ses locaux oui nous alors pour
pour les opérations de vaste envergure
les opérations d'aménagement de vaste
envergure et je crois il me semble j'ai
pas vérifié mais que le président ou la
présidente de cette commission est le
seul membre rétribuer si vous voulez
dont c'est vraiment la fonction
permanente
les autres membres sont là à titre
gracieux façon dont les experts des
ingénieurs de l'équipement des
représentants d'associations de
protection de l'environnement etc etc
cette commission a montré vraiment son
utilité jusqu'à pim
donc le fait de ces thèmes bien normal
complètement incompétent en matière de
débat public alors débat public c'est un
cercle justement relativement large en
fait qu'à l'onu la loi a la compétence
elle a été acquise notamment par le fait
que la france a ratifié la convention
d'un russe aussi avec cette idée que du
coup on devait faire un petit peu plus
participer le public
néanmoins c'est vrai que par rapport aux
autorités administratives indépendantes
jusqu'à présent elle avait gardé un côté
administratif c'est à dire que le débat
public était uniquement celui prévu pour
les administrés pour les citoyens
usagers de certains services publics est
essentiellement comme tu le dit pont
pour l'aménagement bourré travaux aussi
d'expropriation où elle est compétente
de manière obligatoire c'est à dire que
c'est la loi qui lui a donné
son secteur de compétence est ici c'est
je pense la première fois que ce sont
les pouvoirs publics même qui en matière
plutôt constitutionnel et citoyenne
c'est à dire un petit peu hors de son
cadre habituel lui ont donné la
compétence d'encadrer le débat mais
encore une fois ça reste logique avec sa
compétence d'organisation du débat
public même si cette fois ci il aura une
ampleur un petit peu différent parce
qu'aller à l'habituel j'adore ces 20%
vous le disiez le président en
l'occurrence le président de cette
commission est la seule personne
rémunérée et servait génération fait
polémique par mois elle a fait tellement
polémique que chantal jouanno qui est
donc cette présidente s'est retirée de
l'organisation du débat
ce qui évidemment chez vous en france
elle reste quand même prévision c'est
quand même bizarre c'est à dire de
garder la balle c'est ce que font valoir
un certain nombre de ministres dont
benjamin griveaux si elle ne travaille
pas tout principe pourquoi reste del
presidente et pourquoi rester tel
rémunérés soit vrai que c'est pour le
moins que c'est pour le moins curieux
donc sûrement aussi d un certain
désaccord politique
ça semble pas être le grand amour entre
chantal jouanno et le gouvernement non
plus donc voilà ce qu on attend le
défaut plutôt leur le sent dans ses
propos le débat l'organisation des
débats la nécessité du débat
oui mais enfin dès le début semble
qu'elle n'a pas été enfin elle avait
l'air de râler dès le début dans will
save food faudrait vraiment que soit
assuré de tout il ya une réunion qui
s'est fait sur l'organisation ou
n'étaient pas présentes
voilà visiblement ce n'est pas le
l'osmose parfaite quoi donc
elle aime un propos assez intéressant il
consistait à dire que d'après ce qu'elle
avait vu remonter des doléances locales
notamment la question des rémunérations
des hauts fonctionnaires et des
politiques étaient tellement prégnante
dans tout ce qu'elle voyait arriver que
apparemment
là enfin l'argumentation été assez fine
en disant mon propre salaire je vais pas
donner une appréciation dessus mais
c'est une question dont les pouvoirs
publics mériterait de se saisir de l'eau
apparemment elle fait partie de ce qui
est en débat donc elle s'en sort en
précisant que cette question est une
question qui dépasse un peu son seul cas
personnel et qui est con et je ne sais
pas il ya décidément palestine et 0 gros
le la rémunération de ddd président de
ce genre d'instance comme le comme le
oui oui ceci comme le cmem le septième
choix au csa par exemple il ya six
présidents de commissions et mieux payés
quel donc l'autorité des marchés
financiers à l'abri drame mieux payés
mais enfin après sa flore j'ai dit
peut-être que des six premiers sont des
hommes isolés sous les projecteurs à
cause de cette organisation nationale
est à mon sens est là c'est bien fait de
s'écarter de ce débat notamment pour ne
pas créer la sphère fillon dans ce débat
là s'il devait s'organiser de manière
assez apaisés
il était peut-être cinq en tout cas elle
n'en fasse plus partie qu'elle quitte la
commission ensuite c'est une autre
question mais sur l'organisation du
débat national
évidemment on pourra peut-être mieux
discuter si on n'a pas cette idée en
tête ces flux de la vie d'edouard
philippe je pense que sa démission ça
non démission est un épiphénomène qui
n'est pas perçue mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est un peu la police
d'alors d'abord sur le niveau de
rémunération parce que on est quand même
dans une époque
ça aussi c'est fin c'est ces caricatures
en coop la tête à tous ceux qui gagnent
plus de 1000 à 2000 euros par mois et on
va mettre tout le monde à 2000 et ça va
être génial alors on a essayé ça entre
1917 et 1989 quelque part sur sur une
partie si nice est de le relever je
caricature et c'est à moyennement
fonctionné parce que en plus tout le
monde n'était pas admis mme albernaz
c'est bon ça c'est insupportable c'est
parfaitement supportable moi j'entendais
j'entendais sur une radio des auditeurs
qui appelait et le type disait vous
rendez compte chaque député a quatre ou
cinq assistants ça ne coûte un pognon de
dingue comme a dit à quelqu'un qu'on
connaît aussi ses scandales etc
non c'est pas scandaleux c'est pas
scandaleux parce que cinq collaborateurs
parlementaires par parlementaire c'est
pas assez
ça n'est pas suffisant pour que l
charlène le sait mieux que moi pour que
le parlement puisse disposer vraiment de
compétences extrêmement forte et alors
si on va alors il ya probablement 150
têtes à couper du côté de bercy où là il
s'agit en effet de hauts fonctionnaires
man john n'est pas aux fonctionnaires
les présidents des autorités
administratives indépendantes ne sont
pas fonctionnaires ils bénéficient de
cette rémunération pendant le temps
qu'ils exercent leurs fonctions et
ensuite alors certains regagne peut-être
leur corps d'origine sensationnel et
énarque
oui elle évitera sénatrice accumulé des
plus et doit enfin l'été et est décédé
vers l'administrateur civil ou
intérieure et donc tout ça alors j'ai vu
même là dans un magazine que je disais
l'autre jour la rémunération par exemple
du vice-président du conseil d'état
qu'est le premier fonctionnaire de
france qui doit avoisiner aussi celle de
madame jouanno me moi ça ne me choque
pas ça me choque pas que des gens
gagnent beaucoup d'argent ce qui me
choque c'est qu'on dise que six ans
gagne moins avance portera beaucoup
mieux ce qui me choque peut-être c'est
le fait de savoir que en effet 150
fonctionnaires de bercy gagne plus que
le président de la république ça ça
probablement il faudrait qu'on aille
mettre notre nez là dedans la cour doit
les amateurs des peut-être noms dont les
directeurs d'administration laversines
les directeurs adjoints les
sous-directeurs on sait qu'ils sont très
grassement rémunérés au delà du niveau
auquel sont rémunérés leurs homologues
dans les autres ministères bears avec un
totalement même à titre protocolaire une
collègue qui avait été directrice
générale de l'enseignement supérieur
autant de claude allègre c'est francine
demichel qui me racontait ya quelques
temps que lorsqu'elle voulait aller à
bercy pour parler argent avec ses
collègues directeurs du ministère on la
mettait face à un sous directeur
elle était directrice générale de
l'enseignement supérieur
protocolairement l'équivalent d'un
directeur général de ministère à bercy
c'est ainsi qu'hier elle nous rappelle
l'elysée c'est insupportable
il faut que tout cela cesse ça n'a pas
cessé jamais sans c'est donc là
peut-être qu'il faudrait vous mettez de
l'argent qu'est ce que vous devez faire
marrer quand même une
c'est celle de la connaissance que en
tant que citoyen on peut avoir de ce
type de huy de glisser coordination
découvert d'abord savoir de cette
commission
et puis le
des rations en effet de leur présidence
je veux dire c'est vrai que c'était dans
une opacité fait alors on prétend que
les grilles sont les mêmes pour tous les
fonctionnaires en réalité comme si ça
n'est pas vrai et peut-être que les
choses apparaissent plus juste quand
elles apparaissent plus clair et plus
transparente je reprends ici le
vocabulaire de toutes les dernières lois
qu'on a voté voix sur la moralisation
loi sur la transparence de la vie
publique politique des fonctionnaires
etc
moi j'ai le sentiment que c'est une
aspiration qui montent sans cesse et ce
besoin de mieux connaître pour mieux
comprendre et mieux appréhender alors
après la question de la justice
elle est toujours évidemment difficile à
à calibrer qu'est ce qui est plus juste
pour quelqu'un qui sera moins juste pour
quelqu'un d'autre mais je crois que
profondément la découverte de ce type de
salaire dans un moment aussi critique
que celui qu'on est en train de vivre en
termes de cohésion nationale peut
apparaître comme légèrement choquant par
rapport à cette idée que voilà on est au
courant de certains avantages à
l'arrivée ce complot que ça
malheureusement ça nourrit en ce sens
aux choses et c'est que public en effet
pas forcément mal pays il ya des il ya
quand même
non mais enfin c'est une oeuvre pardon
mais c'est une infime minorité imminente
et voilà non non non mais il ya aussi
d'un mois je ne me plains pas non je ne
suis pas c'est vous alors justement pour
les enseignants il faut aller abou dhabi
vaut à vue
oui mais je n'y vais pas c'est paris iii
paris iv et paris
alors vas un peu de paille à la sorbonne
d'abou dhabi et je crois que c'est payer
500 euros par jour
oui mais bon face à un choix non mais
aussi billy tu étais et j'ai entendu un
portail très amusant parce que c'est
vrai que les enseignants qui vont là bas
il était allé est vrai qu'ils sont
traités comme des comme des rois certes
oui ils restent dans leur hôtel pendant
dix pendant des jours il ya rien à faire
là parfois du sable et le loup et le
louvre
non il faut pas plus pour en revenir à
ce salaire de madame jadot donc qui fait
il ya il y avait 1
une remarque dont nicolas gars vous qui
est christian delporte qui dit qui dit
au fond peut-être qu'ils vont on veut
revenir sur ce voile affalée sur le cas
de madame jouanno pose surtout la
question de cette ou ces anciens
ministres responsables publics membres
des cabinets ministériels bénéficions
après leur débat de sinécures offert par
une république bien généreuse crois que
c'est une question qu'on peut se poser
néanmoins bon il ya beaucoup là aussi
deux c'est écrit à la manière d'une
fable de la fontaine et il ya justement
un peu de paraboles la danse etc c'est
trop mais il ya une réalité qui est
celle de ces autorités administratives
indépendantes à mon sens sont beaucoup
trop longs créer une autorité
administrative de régulation de chaque
secteur dans lesquels on crée une oie
aujourd'hui ça devient véritablement
abusif le sénat a essayé de mettre de
l'ordre là dedans il ya quelques années
en créant une liste en essayant créer un
statut à part entière mais néanmoins je
pense pas qu'on a vraiment régler les
choses à ce niveau là et on reproche
parfois ces autorités administratives
indépendantes parce qu'elles sont
indépendantes d'être aussi un petit peu
des fiefs de d'endroit pour recaler dans
la politique dont il a causé du sénat
également on dit ça de du conseil
économique social et environnemental et
ça pose aussi la question de ce qu'on
fait de nos anciens festivals en
puissance se lance en politique de crise
on doit tout gaza
voilà donc cela dit c'est un truc très
française que je pour la presse pour la
presse c'est pareil tous les
journalistes qui ont bien bien servi
différentes causes se retrouvent sur
public sénat sur la chaîne de
l'assemblée animé des émissions que
personne ne regarde
ils sont là ils sont sûrs sont tout à
fait correctement payés ils n'ont plus
d'émissions sur les grandes chaînes sur
les grands trucs mais bon ils ont bien
servi le truc
donc on les recase pourquoi il ya
spécificité c'est pas si les françaises
déficit hydrique ou les humains peu
paratexte ul avec cette idée dit des
fois qui peut alimenter la critique de
créer une république des fiefs en tout
cas cette fameuse après
vol de twitter mais faut quand même se
poser la question de l'utilité de ces
sinécure entre guillemets quoi donc
est ce qu'il ya un réel travail oit ces
cas rien à sa question là c'est le
supprimer ce qui coûte cher et qui ne
fonctionne pas ou qui font que tu te
fatigues fonctionne pas du tout
d'ailleurs
mais en revanche la cette commission
manifestement elle fonctionne et josiane
après le niveau de la rivière la science
du président a présenté dans notre
question enfin on sait que là pour pour
les ax et c'est l'autorité de contrôle
des nuisances aéro des nuisances sonores
aéroportuaires acnusa qui est pointée
par la cour des comptes depuis qu'elle
existe c'est à dire que le niveau de
rémunération de son président est très
élevé par rapport au budget dont elle
dispose et au regard de l'efficacité de
ce machin la sadc dans le viseur de la
cour des comptes depuis depuis que la
cnsa existe pour les autres il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de choses d'ordre eu
scandale au sénat avait quand même
recensé dans le rapport qu'il avait fait
sur la proposition doit sur les
autorités publiques indépendantes et
administratives indépendantes certains
vingtaine d'autorités administratives
indépendantes dont le siège était
carrément vides de tout fonctionnaire y
travaillant et voilà il ya eu quand même
bon on ne fait le ménage un petit peu là
dedans et puis les ied des ménages s'est
mangé j'ai fait des missions pendant
deux ans pour le le haut conseil de
l'évaluation de la recherche et
d'enseignement supérieur à titre gratuit
simple mais défrayer on est payé dans
les transports a tous je ne les fais
deux ans et c'était une très belle
expérience
quand je suis arrivé le
le siège de l'autorité était rue
vivienne à paris non loin de la fp et
quand je suis parti c'était de l'autre
côté du périphérique dans des locaux qui
était d'ailleurs un peu pourri mais
qu'es tu vois la fin vous voyez il ya
quand même une rationalisation il ya pas
croire que il reste en place et c est ce
que disait mon collègue delporte était
d'après ce que j'en comprends était
plutôt relatif à ce qui se passe après
en sortie de fonction oui il a fait le
rock garage pour demain mais il faut
faire attention quoi quand on pense
qu'on commence à parler de tous ces
symboles conseil d'état mais il ya des
instances très utile on a parlé du cs en
parlerait de la cnim de laquelle
beaucoup d'autorité elle sera
indépendante ne sont pas du tout
uniquement relégué du modèle français
n'ont l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire un
truc puis dans un box boxeur fait mal
qu'une championne de karaté
oui c'est ça l'essence wade ce grand
débat on sait pas très bien comment tout
va ça va ça va se passer
est ce que est ce que il ya un périmètre
qui va être attribué aux sujets qu'il
faut discuter
chantal jouanno justement disait mais
non il faut pas faut pouvoir discuter de
tous sinon ça n'a aucun intérêt et en
même temps on voit bien qu'il ya des
sujets qui pourront
c'est pour peut-être discuter ou qui
n'aboutiront pas à des changements mais
le vrai problème que ça pousse c'est que
soit on ouvre tout est là c'est une
sorte de tsunami ou effectivement les
gilet jaune dont on voit bien que c'est
quand même pas la finesse qui les
caractérise ils vont être là en disant
contre la peine de mort contre les
immigrés contre le contre le mariage
pour tous ils vont vouloir remettre tout
ça en cause
hélas là heureusement et quand même
quelques esprits intelligent qui débat
tension l'action on n'y va pas mais
alors du coup je dire on se recoupent
encore de cette marche est de 2,2 en
vociférant pensez vous alors oui on y
voit les jeunes et parfois y aller donc
c'est un peu le fruit du débat
puis après je veux dire ce sans aucun
mépris veut dire que que affluent
passionné par le la vie des gens qu'on
voit sur les ronds-points qui s'exprime
de façon assez curieux jeu franchement
je m'en fous je dirais de cake qu'est ce
que ça va nous apporter
effectivement à par défaut couper les
têtes vous faut supprimer le sénat va
céder des revendications qui ne qu'ils
sont mais tout grotesque phison une qui
une qui sort en dit bah oui pourquoi pas
mais mais pourquoi pourquoi le sénat
pourquoi la démission de macron le feu
ça n'a aucun sens
je pense qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver les questions du débat qu'ils
soient des questions d'intérêt général
parce que les questions d'intérêts
individuels comme
vous le dites on s'en fout complètement
il faut trouver des questions d'intérêt
général et collectives parce que ça fait
un peu ça la démocratie d'intérêt
général et collective qu'on puisse
mettre sur et qu'on soit d'accord sur
sur effectivement sur les questions et
sur les sujets dont il faut débattre à
partir de là à partir du moment où il ya
une adhésion à ce périmètre d'intérêt
général
oui mais on ne sait pas encore on attend
la lettre des manuels macron kiwi mail
par exemple définit on peut pas déjà
défini dans des zones la france et
insoumise qui disent va de toute façon
on va pas parler du rétablissement de
l'impôt sur la fortune donc on ne
participera pas au débat
chacun se demande alors si ces idées qui
vous aiment un sujet qui vous plaît s'il
vous plaît qu'il n'est pas dans le débat
maudite décrit parfois y'a plus personne
ne s'y attendait gilet jaune qui était
interrogé par un journaliste qui disait
bon pas très bien si on fait un débat
qu'est ce que vous voudriez voir comme
question comme sujet posé par exemple
notamment dans le référendum quel
question alors dans le référendum je
voudrais qu'on pose comme question
la peine de mort alors je suis contre la
peine de mort mais il faudrait remettre
la peine de mort pour un certain nombre
de crimes notamment sur les enfants etc
c'est alors qu'on en est de la
restauration monarchique prestement ces
gens qui commencent à pour être joint
c'est non mais c'est cela c'est pas
possible
oui mais pas possible je pense que la
bce ivg tous ces sujets aux policiers
parce que parce que tu aurais de
déception ou à priori ou une déception
et posters et il faut sur deux aux déçus
des décès ou des décisions qui seront
prises au pea tellement d'attentes
différents traits on est dans un
kaléidoscope de fous qu'eux ou de sport
forcément les gens qui seront déçus mais
ce que l'europe a oublié une chose c'est
que cette initiative et les
présidentielles et gouvernementales et
que c'est n'est donc ni une
revendication des gilet jaune ni de la
masse des noces aiderait pour j vocifère
reprend la la la
le gouvernement a essayé d'installer ce
grand débat national pour donner une
réponse justement la plus générale est
la plus politique aussi à ce mouvement
c'est un choix c'est un choix qui dès le
départ et balisé d'ailleurs puisque les
pouvoirs publics ont laissé entendre et
d'en camp vous consultez le site grand
débat national point gouv.fr ckoi à la
suite vous voyez bien que seules quatre
thèmes sont ouverts qui sont bien seriez
notamment dans les sous thèmes qui
doivent être ouverts comme la
citoyenneté l'acquisition de la
citoyenneté la question de savoir aussi
comment sont redistribuées les impôts et
cetera mais au moins je crois pas que ce
grand débat soit normalement censé être
le lieux de rediscuter de questions
sociales et ce qu'a fait le gouvernement
aussi c'est de créer des butoirs c'est à
dire on n'aura pas le droit de discuter
de ce si ceux là sont encore toutes les
questions de société un conte qualifie
comme ça aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il
ivg le mariage pour tous la peine de
mort est néanmoins car il dit est ce que
ç'a pris les saisons à je ne sais pas si
chantal jouanno a une expertise sans fin
supposons que les expertises débat elle
dit si on commence à dire il y aura pas
talent est tel était le sujet ça ne va
pas marcher
ce qui comme il faut laisser les gens
discuter quitte alors savez ce qui est
assez hypocrite parce que les gens
discutent et quitta ce mardi aucune
décision de ce genre tout y amène une
grande erreur de ceux de ce grand débat
pour le moment peut-être que l'avenir ne
nous fera mentir c'est la question du
résultat c'est à dire qu on lui dit
qu'on va débattre on ne sait quoi ce
débat va servir et le risque est de
reculer pour mieux sauter puisque
finalement on fait ça pour essayer de
cristalliser les tensions et pour
essayer d'inciter les gens à aller au
dialogue mais si au final comme tous les
grenelles qu'on a fait grenelle de
l'environnement grenelle des ondes qu'on
aime de l'électronique de la mer etc
c'était la mode sarkozy lé grenelle
si maintenant ce grand débat national se
solde par un rien du tout on va avoir
une grande voie là
attention à posteriori en dix ans va
finalement nous a à nouveau pris pour
des imbéciles on nous en parler pour ne
rien ne rien dire et c'est un peu le
risque c'est à dire que quand vous
donnez des sujets ouverts et des butoirs
sans dire finalement quelle en sera la
synthèse la synthèse elle sera toujours
récupéré par les pouvoirs publics et les
pouvoirs politiques donc ça n'a plus
rien d'un débat national et c'est un peu
le risque à mon avis concours c'est que
le gouvernement prend beaucoup le soin
de ne pas explicité la démarche de fin
de ce débat c'est ce qui est un peu les
skis à leur sens il ya une démarche très
intéressante initiative très
intéressante c'est celle de dmr des
yvelines notamment de karl olive maire
de poissy et que tous vers des registres
disposition dans cette visite très pour
recueillir à la fois leurs doléances et
leurs propositions
on regarde insultes et depuis ça donne
une indication de ce don veulent
discuter les français que ce soit dans
les halls d hôtel de ville sur internet
ou les réseaux sociaux durant trois
semaines les élus de génération terrain
ont recueilli les doléances de leurs
administrés une initiative qui fait
suite à leur rencontre le 7 décembre
dernier avec le président emmanuel
macron 2000 contributions ont ainsi été
récoltés dans quinze communes yvelinoise
saint germain en laye de sujets deux
thématiques principales la fiscalité une
opposition on pouvait s'en douter au
rétablissement de diesel et puis une
autre thématique qui a été très très
très importante
la baisse du train de vie de l'état et
la baisse de la dépense publique
l'expression démocratique avec la prise
en compte du vote blanc ou encore les
retraites font également partie des
préoccupations exprimées par les
citoyens des thèmes quelque peu en
décalage avec les thématiques choisies
pour le grand débat national
il était important que
les différents interlocuteurs nos
gouvernants puissent s'imprégner sans
filtre sans ambages sans thématique
particulière de ce que ressentent les
administrés et quelles sont leurs idées
pour la france
intitulé nos idées pour la france le
document regroupant les 2000
contribution a été remis au président de
la république ainsi qu'au premier
ministre et au président du sénat une
semaine avant le coup d'envoi du grand
débat national
alors après on peut discuter on va dire
il ya pas à 100 % de la population n'y
participerai mais enfin c'est quand même
une initiative intéressante se trouve ce
qui peut dire que voilà le contexte de
mes d'extrême violence
ouais dans lequel on se trouve moi c'est
ça qui me supportent assez loin possible
tout ce qui peut canaliser cette
violence est là et comment dirais-je
faire prendre conscience aux gens que la
démocratie ça peut être violent mais ça
peut être ça doit être violent dans le
débat la démocratie c'est délibéré c'est
se parler se parler entre soi même et
surtout même si on ici ont des toilettes
même si on n'est pas d'accord et en
démocratie on n'est jamais le propre de
la délibération c'est d'essayer de
trouver la solution la moins mauvaise
et cette solution la moins mauvaise elle
est toujours provisoire donc c'est du
débat constant
quand on sortira des menaces des coups
de poing des permanences de
parlementaires dévasté des murs monter
des murs de parpaings montée devant chez
elle a écouté pendant la nuit et
séraphin thème la violence des coups de
poing enfin les noëls playboy hayden
alors quand on au moins parler si si les
gens essaient de se parler ou même de
consigner sur un registre ce qui le ceux
qui les entendent vouloir etc
enfin deux déjà rien que cela c'est
positif
c'est positif d'essayer de faire entrer
dans le canal démocratique
cette violence parce que si on en reste
aux menaces aux coups de poing
non c'est un cadre de cet accord ne
serait pas la solution
ça te dis ça par l'absurde le premier
ministre oui il est déjà très bref un
combat fait que tous ces gens aillent
voter déjà c'est parce que je pense que
c'est alors il ya la reconnaissance du
vote blanc ce qui est ce qui est quand
même une revendication qui est assez
désarmés qui n'est pas que les gens se
déplacent que j'ai à dire je suis
intimement persuadé que 95% des gilets
jaunes eux ne vont pas voter
diable bof salade que vous faites pareil
cueillir ya un type qui s'appelle nicole
des leaders et dire oui puisque 90% des
gens veulent la démission de mâcon avait
les mêmes sondages c'est une âpre et
mégane a certainement probablement le
pape y pensiones par là que si les
français allaient voter je veux dire ce
serait déjà quand même la première chose
la démocratie c'est une chance c'est
peut-être pas le meilleur des systèmes
enfants n'en connais pas d'autre pas de
meilleur alors que les français aillent
voter que il s'engage en politique des
partis et des syndicats
et en france il ya quand même tout
l'éventail et tout d'un coup c'est ces
gens découvrent que ils peuvent
s'exprimer qui s'exprime dans un parti
politique qui me dit qu'ils
s'intéressent à des cahiers dans les
mairies et puis le cahier de doléances
et malheureusement un peu qu'ils me
rappellent tristement l'histoire de
france notamment c'est comme ça qu'a
commencé la révolution tristement pour
essayer d'éviter que les commandes
une prennent ça comme une forme de
revendication historique pour l'heure le
21 janvier
sur ces entrefaites jeu intéressant qui
consistait à dire que le cahier de
doléances à cette époque là est un
cahier qui était associée notamment à
l'élection des députés et à leur mandat
même si les mandats impératifs sont
interdits en france
c'était une manière aussi de donner en
quelque sorte à la personne qu'on venait
d'élire des désormais des lignes
directrices de ce qu'on aurait aimé
qu'il prenne à hacker est aujourd'hui à
mon avis encore le nouveau risque de ces
cahiers de doléances et qu'ils sont
déconnectés de tout résultat on vous
ouvre des livres des livres d'or donné
le sentiment mais voilà elle ne ne
critiquons pas il ya un problème avec la
canalisation de la violence dont ont
parlé c'est à dire que pour canaliser la
violence il faut un vecteur d coûte
c'est à dire donner le sentiment qu'on
va entendre une voix ou le vrai problème
c'est qu'on a du mal à avoir une seule
voix donc on a ouvert à tous
mais alors si on ouvre à tous essayons
de ne pas faire à mon sens une sorte de
fausse réponse en donnant du coup le
sentiment que mais qu'est ce qu'on
allait faire
si vos biens dans les saisies dans le
cynisme fives la dose de carlo ni le dmr
des yvelines on voit bien les sujets qui
préoccupent or il ya évidemment les
sujets fiscaux lisf c'est à dire mais on
va pas défaire souviens de mon facebook
donc on roule exclu un peu mais alors si
alex qu évidemment le tout dire la
plupart d'une majorité des des gens qui
sont dans les rues qui sont pour le
retour 17 ans
comment fait
n'a pas dit que normalement on aurait dû
faire une évaluation des bleus ils vont
faire en 2019 qui vont là bas c'est bien
sûr qu'ils m'ont dit adhérer il faut
changer maintenant et pas plus c'est sûr
que c'était la même chose avec hollande
n'était pas loin d'être la même chose
aussi
c'est quoi il va falloir alors on peut
adopter le système étasunien on voit
tous les deux en un
où en est en campagne électorale
permanente le prenne pour pour la
présidentielle aux états unis d'amérique
tous les trois ans on est en campagne on
sait que la participation plus ligne 59
cents beaucoup plus facile parce qu'on
disait la dernière fois où je suis très
bien mais on disait que de l'erreur
c'était qu'on ait les élections tous les
cinq ans à la fois de l'assemblée
nationale et du président suit et on
s'était dit que ce qui était pas mal
c'est pour le bien du coup les gens qui
ne sont pas que masques peuvent le dire
peuvent l'exprimer de manière
démocratique l'une des deux thèmes
justement qui est le cas alors il ya
évidemment les thèmes fiscaux il ya
évidemment l'immigration et qui revient
alors que c'était pas si j'ai posé ma
phase aller les gens veulent en discuter
pourquoi pas après tout et il ya quand
même derrière sociale le déficit de
démocratie
l'impression du déficit de démocratie et
c'est vrai que quand on regarde quand
même les choses le mouvement du gilet
jaune
il ya quand même une crise de la dette
de la démocratie ne crédite n'ont pas
joué de l'arasement tête exister dans la
présentation assez pas la même chose
mais toujours la même chose
la représentation porte en elle même
génère forcément en elle même cette
cette crise c'est pas quelque chose le
ver est dans le fruit dès le début dès
que des cons on ne peut pas
techniquement permettre à tout le monde
la vraie alors la démocratie authentique
ce serait la démocratie qui s'exerce
dans le canton d'appenzell et dans le
demi canton de chez plus quoi en suisse
et vous sur le forum
c'est à dire que cinq fois ou six fois
par an les jeunes sur le pré et on ne
demande pas aux gens de répondre à une
question qui leur est posée parce que le
système référendaire n'est pas un
véritable système démocratique
l'actuel celui qui détient le pouvoir
celui qui pose la question c'est pas
celui qui répond le vrai système
démocratique c'est de permettre au
peuple de formuler lui même les
questions et d'y répondre
voilà voilà la revendication des vins
dits de la média la revendication du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne bien
mais vous imaginez on va on va réunir
les 45 millions de les 46 millions
d'électeurs
on va là bas de manière locale alors de
manière de manière locale les systèmes
de systèmes existent ni combien
directeur cela mobilise style les maires
organisent des référents noble et
surtout qu'on sait c'est un propos c'est
de démocratie passe par le plan local
c'est peut-être aussi d'abord une
question de deux concernés on est plus
facilement concernés plus on a peut-être
plus de réponses à voir et c'est un
apprentissage très fort de la démocratie
le dernier référendum local c'était sur
l'aérodrome de nos jeunes des landes
n'était pas tout à fait locale c'était
départemental les départementales et les
gens ont voté pour l'aérodrome
enfin pour les records
finalement là encore il n'a pas donc
cela représente vous avez raison alors
il n'y a rien de la démocratie
représentative du style direct et mais
il ya aussi et le fait que les gilles
l'égide des jaunes d'oeufs sont pas
roses sont ils représentés ici par les
partis d'opposition
il part les indices cac juste en
revanche ça c'est vrai que cette cette
dose de proportionnelle qui est dont on
parle est un serpent de mer etc
il va bien falloir y passer je suis
enfin je suis pas favorable à la
proportionnelle intégrale chasse fait
dans ce cas là ça devient en berne un
certain temps en belgique on se marche
pendant un an et demi il n'y a pas de
gouvernement
que faut il ya évidemment un
gouvernement en place et les belles s'en
sont très bien portés oui il n'ya pas
qu'en belgique ou mais la
proportionnelle intégrale c'est
ingérable
parce que ça c'est cette c'est gérable
mais il faut une espèce une grande
sagesse qu un consensus faut que les
partis s'entendent entre eux bon mais
mais mais ça c'est juste et vrai que le
dire qu'en gagnant taris de la
représentativité n'est pas la
représentation non la représentation
c'est toujours la même chose c'est
vouloir pour la représentativité c'est
vouloir comme cov et il ya moins de mon
point de vue une grosse difficulté dans
ce dans ce débat kèlè kèlè ce postulat
au titre duquel celui qui me ressemblent
va vouloir comme moi je voudrais
pourquoi je ne comprends pas je je peux
me dire il n'y a pas assez de
professeurs des universités qui siège au
parlement
mais non mais qu'est ce qu'un collègue
voudrait exactement comme quand je
n'étais pas bon dans les profits vers
citer tout le monde passe pas comme les
rangements et moi je ne pense pas comme
une honte
celui qui me ressemble pensent comme moi
voudrait comme moi je voudrais moi je
sais que c'est cette même jeu mais ça
n'empêche que il n'ya pas vain le rôle
de la politique aussi c'est un peu
d'exorciser les tensions de planifier sa
saisie pour faire la vo non c'était ça
qui est avec qui avait dit ça y est le
rôle du parlement aussi c'est d'eux que
les tensions se voit là ça ne joue plus
son rôle là c'est vrai moi je crois
surtout que dans tout ce qu'on dit il ya
la même question qui est celle de les
institutions de la vème république on a
beaucoup parlé sur les ronds points
c'est bien on sera approprié la
constitution pas forcément toujours sous
les meilleurs auspices mais cette
question c'est celle aussi de savoir si
notre parlement nous représente comme on
disait est de savoir aussi si même si on
prend le postulat d'une démocratie
représentative qui est le nôtre avec un
correctif de démocratie directe c'est
notre article 3 de la constitution
on a une souveraineté représentative
mais aussi avec un correctif de
référendaire la question c'est aussi de
savoir si aujourd'hui nos partis
politiques aujourd'hui l'organisation de
nos élections tous les cinq ans avec un
fait majoritaire qui fait que le
président pense toujours de la même
manière que le parlement qui pense
toujours de la même manière que son
premier ministre et que toutes les
autres les hautes autorités de la
république
est ce que ce système n'est pas devenu
aujourd'hui intolérable pour une
certaine partie de la population qui a
le sentiment que du coup une forme de
clivage voilà mais entre les
institutions qui l ont un petit pré
carré dans lequel elle vit pendant cinq
ans et les revendications populaires qui
ne peuvent jamais finalement rencontré
cette sphère institutionnelle et moi je
crois que c'est ce schéma là qu'il faut
arriver à briser alors peut-être
malheureusement avec certains artifices
intellectuelle parce qu'on a des
penseurs qui ont parlé de démocratie
délibérative ou en tout cas de
correctifs deux initiatives populaires
là pour donner un petit pour redorer le
blason
la représentation malheureusement ça ne
marche pas mais est ce qu'au moins
donner droit c'est ce que tu disais avec
les cahiers de doléances et à dire que à
partir du moment où on essaye un petit
peu de cristalliser cette volonté d'être
entendu est-ce qu'à partir du moment où
on ouvre quelque chose un petit peu plus
largement que on le fait à l'heure
actuelle ça ne va pas au moins permettre
de canaliser cette violence et donner
l'impression qu'elles peuvent peut-être
entendu par certaines voix même si
malheureuse puisque l'institution ça
existe déjà ce que c'est celle de la
vème république
d'une certaine façon oui parce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure
stéphane si on avait la proportionnelle
ça va obliger les partenaires vous
l'approché intégrée intégrale des
correctifs proportionnelle c'est
indispensable
il y aura peut-être pas une majorité
absolue il faut même peut-être que les
mentalités vont évoluer
regardez oui mais regardez ce qui s'est
exactement les gens à discuter les
partis politiques même à discuter à
s'allier à serbe émotionné mégi savoir
parce que tu as écrit que ceux qui
disent le président de la république au
fond et telus avec 20% des voix au
premier tour et en gros il ya soixante
pour cent soixante comme ou 5 euros 50
1,20 majorité de gens qui sont pas pour
lui c'est quand même vrai c'est vrai
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il est
illégitime
non je parle pas de ses activités et
d'autres pas obligé les parties à
discuter à s'entendre à négocier moi moi
j'y suis expliquant seulement il ya eu
pour moi une époque démocratique
totalement enfin presque idéal je le mot
est sans doute trop fort c'était
l'époque de requins rocard regarde la
majorité et donc tous les projets doit
cheminer obligé d'aller chercher sa
maison et regarder aussi puisque
j'espère qu'on en parlera dans les mois
qui viennent ce qui se passe au
parlement européen tant décrié
responsable de tous les maux et cécile
fait pas beau si tout est moche c'est la
faute de l'europe parfait mais au
parlement européen n'y a pas de système
majoritaire ça veut dire que sur chaque
texte
il faut que les gens essayent de pas de
s'entendre mais au moins et 7 s'écouter
voilà pour pour essayer de tirer la
moins mauvaise solution
il ya des majorités d'idées il ya des
majorités par délibération qu'on fasse
ça au parlement moi j'y suis extrêmement
favorable sauf que je ne suis pas sûr
que nous
soyons prêts sorte de fausse dès qu'on
installe aussi et c'est vraiment la
continuité de ton propos l'idée que le
temps législatif peut être plus long
qu'il ne l'est à l'heure actuelle et
notamment c'est vrai que sous la
présidence de d'emmanuel macro on a tous
fait un peu plus l'urgence et ce risque
là c'est que justement il n'y a plus de
débat et plus ça dure c'est le loup
blanc beaulieu s'est pas tellement ça
c'est que la procédure législative si
elle est vraiment délibéré pied par
payet était mon avis elle sera plus
longue et au moins on n'aura plus le
sentiment d'être en main c'est ça qu'on
puisse arriver à faire quelques réformes
parce que sinon ce que tu les feras pas
mais lui on doit quand même et rien
n'est prévu dans une démocratie de
consensus président macron pour faire
des réformes sur un programme et on peut
pas lui reprocher il assume et applique
son programme les blessés c'est quand
même un minimum
on est vraiment un peuple de deux
conflits de contentieux gaulois répétées
n'ont pas de dollars et fracas les
français aiment le conflit mais je le
vois je mais oui je les vois mon niveau
en tant qu'avocate quand ils essayent de
rapprocher des parties la médiation en
france a beaucoup de mal à trouver sa
place et faire en sorte que les gens se
mettent autour d'une table pour se dire
les choses calmement peut-être un peu de
passion mais quand même en essayant de
sortir par le haut et trouver une
solution et n'est plus dans la politique
du conflit et c
système actuel est le résultat de scop
s'allumant ce que voulait absolument et
du problème du temps c'est à dire que
vous avez raison que idéalement il
faudrait un peu plus de temps et on est
dans une société de l'immédiateté quand
même qu'ils demandaient 100 ans ça va
pas assez vite il faut tout nouveau
taille vite été tout de suite quoi et
c'est alors sa politique m'enfin bon
pour les gouvernants c'est un problème
insoluble enfin pas si c'est soluble
c'est à dire que les choses sont
complexes
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est complexe
et c'est évident mais oui mais à les
faire passer cette idée la ribambelle
oui bah d'accord mais c'est plus ici
l'idée ne passe pas mais on s'y heurte
forcément c'est à muro qu'annonceur il
ya à mon avis juste et je n'ai pas la
solution et je serai très heureuse qu'on
la donne mais il ya un vecteur à trouver
pour que quand on sent une déconnexion
telle entre les revendications
populaires alors d'une certaine base
même si évidemment les gilet jaune sont
pas tous représentatifs de de tous les
français mais il ya quand même une forme
d'illégitimité gouvernementale qui est
en train de mûrir ou en tout cas cette
idée que le l'élite n'est pas toujours
mieux renseignés sur le prix du ticket
de métro etc
c'était aussi il faut arriver à trouver
à mon avis faut arriver à trouver des
réponses à ces questions parce que ça
commence à devenir un vrai qu'il faut
tirer vers le bas
l'élite on en a besoin sont des gens
très réfléchie et sachant qu'il ya des
filles où ça fonctionne très bien où ça
n'existe le vrai après questionnaire
c'est vrai qu'il ya une reproduction des
élites da pour le coup qui est plutôt
scandaleux notamment que c'était le
postulat dans marche c'était d'arriver à
essayer de dire où on va vous donner un
petit peu plus de connexions ils ont
essayé avec ces nouveaux députés qui à
mon sens sont d'ailleurs bien plus rompu
aux exigences de la vie de la société
civile que les autres mais voilà c'est
peut-être encore une étape que
qu'emmanuel mâcon avait pressenti à mon
avis et qui doit aller plus vite ou en
tout cas qui doit être continuée c'est à
dire essayer de pas déconnecter l'un de
l'autre je rappelle quand même que pau
pour l'accès aux élites
en france on n'est pas les si mauvais
jeudi on a quand même un ministre un
ministre du budget qui est fils de femme
de ménage
darmanin nom me souviens faut pas
exagérer c'est pas si mal non plus c'est
pas non plus complètement bloquée d'un
phare était toujours de cette façon mais
ça va les raisons sont pas d'une grande
école
enfin je veux un port dvi i sort les
hommes le tilt mais bon il y donne il
est ministre du budget c'est une belle
réussite et il ya d'autres exemples en
font mais ça s'est décanté les chiffres
que si vous prenez ce palais les les
les élèves de normale sup ou deux on
voit bien que ces hyènes quand même nos
productions c'est souvent des vessies
bien sûr et sur mes bébés mais c'est
trop caricatural célébrer les gens sur
des bosses pas tu n'es pas 100% vrai il
ya aussi une gamme de la science mais ce
n'est sûrement pas ouvrir l'ascenseur
social existe il ya des possibilités
quand on travaille la rue qu'en france
est quand même merveilleux ces
universités ne coûte rien - étudiants
c'est quand même extraordinaire de se
lier ce que je trouve pas ce que est ce
que vous trouvez pas que dans le conflit
actuel afin de débattre qu elle est une
sorte de haine de nous mêmes désirs de à
la fois j'ai entendu quelqu'un disait le
foutu pour foutu on va on va voter le
pen la prochaine fois mais est-ce qu'on
ait ces foutus que ça secoue le pays ses
coutumes c'est ce qui ne marche pas si
mal que ça est ce que c'est ce que la
redistribution et pas relativement forte
est ce que les hôpitaux sont veufs à la
santé peu plus tôt gratuite pour les
vallées dire si mal la phrase de sylvain
tesson qui dit la france et un paradis
peuplé de gens qui se croient en enfer
oui c'est exactement ça c'est pas le
paradis pour tous un oui on est bien sûr
mais bon oui mais il ya quand même et
c'est une mauvaise idée de nous mêmes
notre partition qui font plutôt pas mal
oui ça pourrait toujours être mieux mais
ça des choix qui sont dans la détresse
simplement je l'entends et je le vois
oui mais on peut faire mieux mais il
faut pas qu'il faut pas tout péter ils
font pas tout casser système
d'amortisseurs sociaux
quand vous entendez de vie dans un la
question dès 15 h à la salle je moi je
enfin on bénéficie de services publics
alors qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont là pour
être là aussi toujours mieux mais enfin
c'est pour beaucoup c'est complètement
extraordinaire et je fréquente hélas pas
mal les hôpitaux ans mais mange quand
même je sors de là dedans c'est gratuit
léger bénéficier de conseils de soins
attentifs merveilleux de d'une fin du
sud une médecine qui est à la pointe de
l'une des meilleures du monde et c'est
gratos
enfin je n'en reviens pas je n'en
reviens pas moi même on est quand même
sympa soi mais on doit rien à la fin je
suis usagers des transports qui
fonctionne plutôt bien en ce moment des
transports publics je ne paye pas le
coût de la prestation à son juste prix
le prix du ticket de métro ça doit être
quoi un euro 40 ou quelque chose comme
ça le vrai coût de la prestation si les
usagers qui paient le vrai coup ce
serait aux alentours de 4 euros
on voit même plus ils se retrouvent est
vrai pas vrai pour la culture pour
l'université de l'agriculture
enfin on peut s'inscrire en licence pour
160 euros alors que le coût de la
prestation ses 9000 euros par étudiant
moi j'avais quand j'étais doyen
un parents d'étudiants qui me disait
monsieur le doyen j'ai le droit de
parler parce qu'on a payé combien vous
avez payé madame vous avez payé 156
euros et vous me dites que vous avez
payé ce que coûte votre enfant à la
collectivité c'est 8000 euros et vous en
a payé vous vous en payez 156 main
dessus
il faut pouvoir d'achat et s'exprime
aussi par ce genre de rexel compliqué à
dire aujourd'hui et enfin quand même on
n'est pas dans une situation absolument
fin vous dépassez pas long feu
mais celle de la déconstruction
moi je n'ai pas le sentiment qu'on ait à
faire alors encore une fois on l'a dit
la revendication est très protéiforme on
a beaucoup de mal à savoir où ça va et
qu'est ce qui est revendiqué exactement
mais moi je n'entends pas en tout cas
dans les cahiers de doléances qu'on nous
fait remonter je n'ai pas le sentiment
qu'on a affaire à des français mais
quand on leur niveau de service public
la seule question qui revient c'est
celle de la justice sociale dont tu
essayé de parler avec la halle à la
radio ça en fait partie mais il s'est
passé pas le niveau de service public
qui manque c'est pas la question de
savoir comment la france fonctionne au
niveau de service public qui est en
question c'est une revendication à être
un peu mieux entendus sur cette question
à mon avis essentiellement fiscal je
pense quand même que la politique
fiscale elle doit aussi être et darmanin
a reconnu emmanuel macron aussi en
parlant un peu de manque de pédagogie
sur certaines réformes on va vivre le
prélèvement à la source on est encore
très peu renseigné sur temps cela année
c'est toi qui dis donc justement est-ce
que ça ce n'est pas une erreur
ok alors non plus un rond point
et puis proposons gilet jaune ou en
voilà combien d'emplois vous payent pas
l'impôt sur le revenu soyons justes tout
le monde va le pays d'aller voir ce que
ce que ça va t elle aider l'irak souffre
et est ce que vous le voir peut-être à
travers les hésitations
est ce que vous voyez une sortie de
crise c'est bien il faudrait bien mais
il ya des qu'il ya déjà des conflits
paris l'espace bishop con pour la
première fois je perçois pas comme ça de
sortie de crise c'est très clair c'est
tout et n'importe où mai 68 a commencé
comme ça par un mouvement qu'en tant que
personne ne pouvait définir même et puis
les syndicats ont pris le dessus et donc
il y avait mes interlocuteurs une
mobilisation qui décroît oui mais il
faut pas oublier non plus que la
quantité des lacs est vrai par le maire
on parle de 50000 personnes nous sommes
67 millions de français et ou non notre
premier dans ce qui est en train de
baiser ou moment notre dame des landes
il y avait trente mille personnes qui
étaient là pour soutenir les analystes
et certaines des lampes
là on est sur une base de 50 mx samedi
dernier donc voilà arrêtons aussi de 2,2
sur réagi en disant mais là la france
est dans la rue non la france n'est pas
dans la rue mais un certain nombre de de
gilet jaune qui continue qui vont
envahir peu probablement bourges etc
on va dire qu'elle quelques lieux mais
c'est pas non plus on est on est pas
laver une révolution parce que c'est
parce que les bérurier
dire que la solution c'est celle du
grand débat national peut-être que ce
grand débat national va aboutir à
quelque chose si vraiment on arrive à
entendre les doléances de tout le monde
et en faire une synthèse qui
apparaissent acceptable pourquoi pas
faire confiance je vais je me servais je
vais me spécialiser dans le message
d'espoir je pense et bien levé encore la
donne et faisons confiance au débat
national et on verra ce que ça donne
exactement reviendront display ce qui
est bon de terminer nous avait donné
pour la cagnotte du boxeur ou pas ce
qu'est ce que tu as juste un mot là sur
la cagnotte du boxeur je dirai encore
une fois 67 millions de français 7000
pauvres types qui donnent pour cette
cagnotte je veux dire c'est un
épiphénomène ce qui est dramatique dans
cette cagnotte c'est la réaction des
hommes politiques et des femmes
politiques qui n'ont pas tous condamné
ça qu'après l'utilité des crétins qui
donnent bon parce que litchi a indiqué
la finalité de la cagnotte payer les
frais de justice sur factures d'avocats
alors j'ai compris
non mais c'est ça qui est inquiétant
c'est que tout le monde n'est pas
unanimement condamné savalas après que
des gens qui donnent jeunesse plutôt
avec luc ferry
ces transitions des arbres qui s'en sert
voyez ma lauricisque en date dont il a
dit il a jamais dit il il a dit izama de
leurs armes non létales non létales pas
désormais tabler dagobert excusez moi
mais une matraque ça peut tuer en prison
jusqu'à passer de rien par astronaute
allemand irresponsablement de
déclarations d'amour sont choqués c'est
ce sont des gens d'une matraque portés
situé dans le sud sauvage 8e la sagesse
nous est pas arrivé
la rsa y retourne à ses chats cela dit
le boxeur attaqué le nom ça me choque
pas que le concept concerne deux fonds
servent de ce2 de sa matraque pour se
défendre ou pour réprimer ou menacer sa
phrase comme ça suppose le respect non
médicaux cecchin qui fait que les
policiers mais très peur et tant mieux
mais bon
mais un moment au foot peut-être aussi
répondre c'est des grenades
oui ma foi c'est quand même pas notre
pas normal de voir ces pauvres quinze
jours sur la passerelle à paris en train
de reculer
je suis d'ailleurs je suis d'accord pour
que fait on alors bien en 2009 elle est
de se servir de combien elle que s'est
déclaré eh ben on va les laisser tda
pourquoi vous pouviez relais laisser
débattre entre eux vous voyez que le
grand débat n'ait pas fait des chicots
ténue et on en reparlera probablement
dans le nouveau mieux au taf a très vite
pour ce nouveau numéro
[Musique]
oui moi je viens moi je suis d'accord et
féerie pour le coup alors